now I'm out and about seeing leveling It
Up In Action all across the country
today getting fined for not wearing a
seat belt in this Instagram video was
hardly the look that Rishi sunak was
going for this week he was trying to
show he could lead Britain out of the
Gloom and Scandals of recent years now
you can follow my progress progress has
been hard to come by for the man who
became prime minister in October and the
controversy that dogged his predecessors
hard to shake off
former prime minister Boris Johnson was
the latest to send sunak's attempted
fresh start crashing off course on
Sunday while Johnson was in Ukraine
reports in the British media accused him
of failing to declare that a man he
appointed as chairman of the BBC had
previously helped him secure a loan of
nearly one million dollars big deal said
Johnson's spokesman
but that is what the trickle of sleaze
is becoming for Britain's ruling party
six months after Johnson was forced from
office for one Scandal too many a day
before their chairman Nadeem zahawi
apologized for a careless error having
been reportedly forced to pay six
million dollars to UK tax authorities in
a dispute over his finances he had
previously denied he was trying to avoid
paying tax extra embarrassing for his
party and the government as he was
Finance Minister during the dispute in a
statement zahawi said hm revenue and
Customs concluded that this was a
careless and not deliberate error so
that I could focus on my life as a
public servant I chose to settle the
matter and pay what they said was due
what we do know is that Nadeem brought
his tax affairs up to date and we do
know that the tax bill existed because
he had launched and grown and run a very
very successful business bearing in mind
of course he came here as a refugee free
in conflict and persecution speaking
almost English at all
the big sums at play in the Johnson and
zahawi cases will hardly help the
government's position as it holds out on
new pay deals for nurses ambulance
workers teachers and train drivers
one of the things Rishi sunak had going
for him when he took over as prime
minister was that he wasn't badly
tarnished by the scandals of the Boris
Johnson era despite getting a police
fine for attending Johnson's birthday
party during lockdown but as the
conservative party continues its
decades-long dance with controversy that
Fresh Start is increasingly looking like
a false one Polaris Al Jazeera London